With the blue function complete, the
interpreter jumps back out to where that
function was called and
the current context moves out as well.
Furthermore, this was all part
of the first call to newSaga,
which is now completed.
Running the red newSaga function
a second time would result in drafting
a new separate red context, which
itself contained two new blue contexts.
Almost all the exact
same steps would occur.
And although they would
each happen one at a time,
let's picture them all popping up at
once, so that we can see them without
having to run the entire
simulation one line at a time.
Notice that the values found in these
new contexts will be entirely different
and it's actually stored in
an entirely newSaga variable.
Although the second saga function was
created by the same lines of code
that created the first one,
the two would fail a triple
equals test that compared them.
Creating two equivalent
looking functions, but
have different identities,
is exactly like what
happens when you see an array literal
appearing within a function definition.
Calling that function twice creates
two different array objects.
And so,
this line would log the value false
because the two array objects do not
pass a triple equals comparison.
The same would be true of
these two function objects,
because they were created
by the same lines of code
in two different invocations
of the newSaga function.
What two strings do you think would be
logged as a result of this second call
to the newSaga function?